all right Ramona how are you I'm good
how are you Bryce sorry for the delayed
guard oh that's okay I'm just glad we
could connect at some strange times yes
very eerie strange unchartered territory
but you got to keep smiling we're all
smiling yeah so we're calling these our
quarantine confessionals or quarantine
Diaries just checking in on everybody so
where have you hunkered down you're not
in New York
right I know Mario very graciously
offered for Avery and I to come spend
some time here because my doctor thought
dr. Shay Keith dr. Shay you thought it'd
be very good for my health since I had a
lowered immune system to be by the ocean
because Mario is right on the ocean so I
see the ocean I see that I feel the
breeze it's a beautiful balcony
so I'm good typing isolating here for
ten days you're down in Florida right so
what's it like having the kind of the
family back together you Mario and Avery
all together that's kind of waffle you
know it is wild you know listen we have
a lot of history together
you know Avery says like they said the
band back together again and you know
listen Marta's been very gracious he's
very respectful of my immune system and
being very careful not to go to the
store or the drugstore just
drive-through I get all the photo shoots
delivered because my immune system is
impaired I cannot I have to be an
isolation or self quarantine but if you
want to call it and the thing that we do
together every night is we make dinner
so the first few nights mario made
delicious dinners for us and then I made
some and Avery made some I'm not sure
who's gonna be cooking tonight and then
after dinner around nine nine round 9:30
we watched one or two episodes we chose
Game of Thrones to watch collectively
because there's so many episodes with so
many seasons so we do that and then the
day starts again with Mario making a
nice shape you know he makes these
really good shakes that favorite
maneuvers you put the floors off mom dad
shakes me
wait the morning these these protein
shake and how good can they be let me
tell you Mario makes the best protein
shake you've ever had in your life
he combines like fresh spinach with
celery and apple
and banana and berries and it's so good
we all start off our day with his
protein shake does Mario live there
full-time or is this his vacation place
no he lives here full-time Wow okay does
it kind of gee are you having flashbacks
to old times being met together having
family dinner or is it completely
different
well you know because Mario's been on
his own now for so long it's kind of
nice cuz he really I mean I never knew
him to be such a great cook to make so
many different dishes and he's really
good so he's really good in the kitchen
and he's a real neat phonetic good god
forbid any fingerprints on his Sub Zero
saying I don't like prints you gotta
wipe them off oh yeah everything has to
be like the steady sleep clean like
beyond like like you like you just moved
in clean well I mean there's worse
habits to have yeah but no it looks like
you guys have a nice setup I've been
watching your knaveries workouts on
Instagram yeah she's out for a walk
right now normally if I wasn't speaking
to you I've been doing a nice four mile
walk with her if you have a whole
routine down no actually and I think in
this time people need to have them
cheese I think it's really important to
wake up in the morning and not and take
a shower you know I wake up in the
morning sloppy I'm wearing my robe all
day I'm not washing my hair no every
morning I wake up I take a shower at you
my hair put a chill spot Ramona on my
skin a little light makeup some lipstick
yeah I get dressed nicely I think it's
important to feel like a person still
exactly well you know this is only
adding some fuel to the fire of the fans
of housewives wanting you and Mario to
get back together seeing you guys
together as a family
well you know we were connected we
always will be connected I actually
watched this first episode screener this
morning in preparation for this in that
first episode yet yes of course and I
showed a vulnerability in myself I'm
asking self
because in my mind I think I'm this
youngster and I'm not I am 60 years old
and you have to have a direction yeah
and I feel like an emptiness in me I
can't explain it I used to always wake
up happy and I wake up in this apartment
I start crying I really feel alone
that's a different side of you than
we've seen before actually you know I
think what's very interesting about this
season someone said describe it I might
now word to describe is it's a very
unique season we're showing ourselves in
a different way we're going deeper and
we're exposing our our fears and our
weaknesses and people can relate to that
because you know what no one has a
perfect life you know no one has a
perfect life and anyone says they do
they're lying so I think fans will
relate to that in Ilsan you know I feel
like that you know my husband died and I
haven't felt loved again yet or I'm
divorced and I'm gonna find love again
and you know so I think it's a real
emotion and it's something you know I
was with some of my really close friends
and it's something that I just you know
I think it's because I sold my apartment
that I've had for 25 years and I moved
into a new place and I was feeling very
lost and you'll go through my journey
through all the for the whole season to
see how I'm gonna deal with it how I'd
cope with it and how I managed what was
different about this season that you all
got to that more vulnerable place I
think because even though Bethany is a
very strong character and she's very you
know well-received by the viewers and by
us
she basically can be all walk on
eggshells around her and we couldn't
really be ourselves she just you know
she's such a big personality she kind of
took over the room and there's no air
left for us to meet and I think this
season the fans will be surprised to see
a different side of all of us and and
you know listen we still have our
arguments we still fight but there's a
bomb that's different and there's just
something just so much more special and
just unique their unique yeah I actually
spoke with Bethany in all this because
you know she's doing a lot of work with
be strong and I asked her what it feels
like to have a season of housewives
coming out that she's not on and her
line was that's somebody I used to know
and I want to get your reaction to that
well it's no I don't know if that's true
because we were filming she'd be calling
all the time like what's going on what's
going
what are you doing what's going on
what's going on it's like she'd be
calling us non-stop to find out the dirt
on her dream trip so I don't know you
know boom Oh fear of missing out I guess
so check it when you're so part of
something for so long you know it's hard
to disconnect but we got a new girl in
the group yeah McSweeney how do you feel
about Lea she has a rollercoaster of a
personality which you'll see I think you
can even tell from some of the clips I
kind of looked at I heard and took her
on as my daughter so yeah so I
definitely hold her to another standard
so I was a little tough on her because
you know what I want better from her so
okay so mom the mom side of you came out
the mothering side came out I oh yeah I
want her to toe the line it looks like
there's gonna be a lot of drama with
Dorinda this season something is really
bothering Doreen de always has had a bit
of a temper as we know and I think the
mixes it looks like maybe she has a
little bit more than usual and I always
say people act out when there's
something really going on within
themselves that they can't but they're
not happy with it can't quite figure out
so you're gonna have to watch the show
to see why Dorinda is being the way she
is and do we ever get to the root of the
problem all right
that'll be interesting to see cuz in the
trailer it looks like you're trying to
confront her about it or about something
and she's just not willing to listen or
talk about it you'll have to watch yeah
there's a Dorinda was definitely a
different personality from past seasons
she definitely would fly off the handle
very readily at everyone and it was very
difficult to deal with that because you
know what we all love her you only look
the best for her and I love Dorinda so
you have to see if we were able to get
through to her or not
and what happened or didn't happen it'll
be interesting TV for sure oh yeah well
we might as well talk about each of the
ladies and just get your read on them
this season how are things with in the
land of
ammonia how Sonia in you this year oh
they're good they're good really I mean
I love my son yet you know it's like
emotional tease me like all the girls
like we all do a group texting when they
found out I had Lyme disease I'm at one
point Sonya Tech which is listen you
can't get sick because I need you I need
you around so I can like bother you bug
you know I need you in my life you know
so Sonya and I have a bond that I've
never had any other housewife on the
show and we'll have that forever all
right what about Lou Lou oh my god she
was so much fun to be around
this year when we filmed I really feel
she's gone through a metamorphosis a
change and for me I think it's for the
better and you'll see me interacting
with her one on one on the show and it
was great I think she's just more
grounded she's just more herself she
doesn't have like this pretentious wall
up like you know everything's just cool
no just more like hey what's going on
and if I won't have a drink I'm
responsible I could have a drink so
leave me alone she's just I don't know
she's just a better person I think I
just enjoy her better in my mind that's
how I find her okay
and then there's Tinsley tediously
I mean I kind of tried to adopt her as a
daughter too but you know that was look
you know and she what do we always say
about two things I think you've said
enough with that reaction Tinsley no I
like Tinsley I eat just a beautiful
person inside and out and I just want
her to be happy and I hope she gets
married and has lots of babies okay I
like that wish for her dearly wish that
the bottom of my heart I really do we
got the tagline this week yes
our tagline is I don't need to find love
I love myself but do you really feel
that way because in the first episode we
see you had that little breakdown about
wanting a man to hold you in May
well you're correct oh remember that was
only the first episode we have like 20
to go so you have to see what happens
and we're gonna do the tag lines it's
near the end once I know that's all I
got sex your name yeah
all right but you still would like to
have a life partner you're still looking
for love if I find it I find if I donate
don't you know and that's how I feel
right now
you know I realized that I'm very
blessed in my life I have a wonderful
daughter she's wonderful inside and out
if we fight sometimes but that's like
what mother daughters do but I love her
more than life itself I have a great
group of friends meeting men is never my
problem
I'm very busy I'm very social I can't
even keep up with dome lights and social
engagements I'm invited to I'm very
active I travel a lot I mean I tell a B
I'm LL she talking about the expression
Yolo you only live once
I know Ava I got a new one for you it's
called Elle Elle I'm living life and I'm
living my life I am living the best life
ever and I feel so blessed and yeah so I
can't complain I'm really fortunate I
really am how has the Lyme diagnosis
changed things though has it changed at
all your ability to live life to the
fullest oh I'm a little tired I mean
when I went to Aspen I used to land go
ski half the day and then go out two in
the morning I couldn't do that at nine
o'clock at night I'd want to go to bed
so I would listen to my body because my
doctor Shay
he said Ramona listen to your body don't
push yourself I know you think you're
the Energizer Bunny but you can't you
got to listen to your body so but
they're like then a week after I had my
antibiotics it kicked in and then I was
able to ski you know I was more
energized and I felt really great but
you know I was I was not doing the
alcohol thing and I wasn't staying out
till 2:00 in the morning so I made sure
I got my you know ten hours of sleep
because I need nine ten hours of sleep a
night with this Lyme disease because you
know when your immunity system is low
the best way to repair it the only way
to really repair it is sleep when you
sleep you're repairing your immune
system so I'm forcing myself to sleep at
least nine ten hours a night but I
always stuff like nine hours like that's
why I look so ageless I was gonna say
that's the secret behind uh-huh no it's
true
but now I really make sure and the irony
is I spoke at global Lyme Alliance two
years ago and Yolanda also spoke and I
gave a speech and I thought it was very
important when I said anyone out there
could have Lyme disease at any time it
could be you you you
are you and guess what now it's me
you're actually one of the first people
I saw being very guess where it might be
like hard on social media like self
isolate stay indoors in this moment in
time because it's the only way we can
fight this right is it short term it
worth it
feeling up it's a little bit of pain for
the greater game that's my opinion
hey I think there's no better message to
leave it on I'm asking everybody when
we're doing this because you know if we
were in the studio we'd get a selfie
together our picture so I'm taking a
selfie with everybody in this weird new
computer light so here we go
[Music]